Are there published studies or clinical studies that document results with the rife treatment?
Not that I know of. There are some studies that have shown the benefits of
of using electromagnetic field therapies. I posted one of them on our website that was published in
2023 for colon cancer. There's another one that was published in 2019 on breast cancer, but it'll
go specifically into any frequencies, rife frequencies, we should have talked about electromagnetic
field therapies with frequencies. The issue with that is that in order to get clearance to do a study,
we have to get FDA clearance. Unless you're like comparing it with doing it with
chemotherapy or doing chemotherapy without it, you probably won't get clearance in NIH clearance to
do a study. It takes hundreds of thousands to $1,000,000 to do something like that, but I don't
propose that they will be anything in the future.